bonsoir à lui bon alors on est où là on
est à l'espace champagne de sur samsung
c'est pas faux c'est le test aujourd'hui
comme ça peut vous dire tout ce que j'en
pense qu'on ne retrouve pas aujourd'hui
c'est le fold malheureusement et n'ont
donc je pense que personne n'a pris le
foll dans un rôle le voyez sur une
espèce de cloche avec un effet de miroir
à barcelone bien contrôler strictement
rien et patiente
wait and see
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est l'heure du test du
samsung galaxy s 10 plus je sais plus
j'ai mis la boîte
voilà il a à la volt est lui samsung
galaxy a death plus et encore plein de
choses à dire dessus sparte wade
franchement hyper hyper intéressant il
n'a pas chemin de bois positif mais
aussi des trucs qui vont pas trop bien
bon là je filme avec tue tout vous
expliquer ce qui est bien ce qui est pas
bien vous dirai ce que vous en pensez en
moi bien évidemment en commentaire c'est
une grande journée on va parler
aujourd'hui du samsung galaxy s 10 kg et
la fac est en fait il n'est pas là en
fait il est là samsung galaxy s 10 ça
fait plusieurs jours que je le teste je
me suis bien amusé avec est ce un
smartphone qui n'a quasiment quasiment
que des qualités quasiment à quelque
chose près il ya quelques fois un peu
mais franchement c'est quasiment un sans
faute je trouve que samsung a fait un
excellent boulot sur ce smartphone alors
il ya des choses que j'aime beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup vous allez voir est ce
que j'aime un peu moins qui sont du côté
un peu personnel mais qu'à côté de ça on
peut pas enlever à ce smartphone toutes
les qualités qu'il a je vis beaucoup de
mots qualité vous avez vu hausse fait ça
fait presque placement de produit
qualité qualité non il est vraiment
vraiment top
ça me saoule a fait un excellent boulot
et en plus de ça et je suis très content
parce que j'ai plein de fiches
ça ne semble que en a gentiment donné
merci beaucoup alors c'est immonde
marque vous connaissez très gros savoir
faire un acteur historique on peut
parler design on peut par les crampes
par les photos on peut parler de bonnes
choses on a plein d'informations plein
de choses à signaler aujourd'hui on va
vraiment se concentrer sur ce galaxy s
10 plus d'ici quelques jours on va
parler du galaxy s 10e parce que je
tenais vraiment envie de lui connaître
plus en détail
je veux dire très intime avec lui parce
que je trouve que c'est une très belle
proposition que y aller sur un modèle 5
pouces un peu moins cher qui va toujours
avoir de très bonne qualité
encore une fois nos qualités fil rouge
allez savoir enfin bon on en reparle
dans quelques jours je me mets pas plus
pour l'instant
ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va
regarder de plus près ce s10 plus on a
déjà beaucoup parlé
c'est un petit peu le point d'orgue la
le test pour vous dire vraiment ce que
j'en pense il est vraiment bien on se
met n'a rien on regarde ça ensemble déjà
emprise en avoir que c'est un très grand
modèle on a quand même un écran de 6,64
pouces c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
est très gros mais qui malgré tout
tient bien dans la main et pas trop
massif ça va c'est cool on va commencer
par le truc qui fâche un peu moi ce que
je veux vraiment lui reprocher c'est
l'emplacement des boutons de volume ici
parce que lorsque vous l'avez sur
l'oreille vous passer un coup de fil
vous cherchez les boutons est en fait
vous êtes toujours flirté avec le bouton
bixby c'est pas hyper intuitif j'aurais
plus éventuellement les boutons de
volume plus vers le bas et le bouton x
bio dessus ça reste du point de détail
parce qu'il faut vraiment chercher un
truc à redire autre truc que j'aime moi
j'aime pas trop mais c'est vraiment à
titre personnel parce qu'il faut bien
commencer par cotan peu négatif c'est le
capteur d'empreintes digitales à
ultrasons parce que c'est pas si vous en
souvenez il ya quelques temps quelques
bons mois maintenant on a testé le one +
6 tu es très bon smartphone soit dit en
passant est il avait son capteur
d'empreinte digitale intégrée à l'écran
pour moi c'était la première fois que
tester et je trouvais ça marrant mais je
trouvais pas ça fout parce que ça a été
beaucoup de temps et là quand j'ai
appris qu effectivement des lavoirs le
capteur d'empreintes digitales à
ultrasons j'ai trouvé ça vraiment bien
une belle proposition et je trouvais ça
vraiment intéressant donc je me suis dit
on pose son doigt
ça va vite comme on le fait sur un
smartphone je dirais pas plus tendre
avec un capteur un petit peu standard
sauf que en réalité ce capteur à
ultrasons marche quand il veut bon il
finit par marcher mais c'est pas très
rapide je préfère toujours les capteur
d'empreinte digitale au dos ou alors
carrément sur la tranche donc j'aimerais
vraiment savoir ce qui se passe en
termes de techno à dire je pose mon dos
dessus à il marche ça va on a un peu de
chance mais ça marche quand ça veut des
fois ça marche des fois
voyez là ça met du temps et la
presqu'île mais voilà j'ai pas
complètement couvert donc je repose mon
doigt
j'attends ça finit par marcher le truc
qui a ses dunes c'est pas très rapides
et des fois ça marche pas il faut s'y
reprendre à deux trois reprises voilà ça
c'est vraiment le truc que je regrette
là-dessus aux poches les moyens fans
c'est ça la la petite bulle je le trouve
moins dérangeant dans le s10 dont le s10
plus de trouve quand même grands
voiliers light cherche à vous le cacher
vous avez une partie plus clair et là
vous arrivez sur une partie plus foncée
ça dépend de fonds d'écran pour moi
quand on vous cherche à cacher quelque
chose
c'est là quelque chose à cacher et là
typiquement c'est ça alors et l'idée de
la voir intégrer comme ça d'avoir un
écran plus grand
avec ici une toute petite part noir
frais légère manteau un peu plus grand
mais c'est vraiment vraiment minime ceux
du pont de détails
c'est un sens c'est vraiment bien ces
grands écrans l'écran infiniti comme ça
je pas vraiment beau maintenant ce petit
c'est pas un personnage là c'est quand
même un peu plus grand parce qu'ils sont
le latéral
je suis moins fan c'est quelque chose de
très personnel je trouve ça moins
efficace alors lorsque vous regardez des
vidéos comme ça on ressent le mettre en
plein écran ça dérange pas a par contre
dès que vous le mettez tout de suite en
plein écran d'envoyer ça vous fait cette
espèce de gros trucs là alors on peut se
dire on le met dans l'autre sens comme
ça on le cache
mais on l'a quand même sur le côté pour
moi c'est pas parfait pour moi c'est une
étape une étape nécessaire par laquelle
passe samsung mais ça très clairement ça
va finir par disparaître parce que c'est
pas complètement génial et c'est pascal
mieux aboutit donc bon je continue à
maintenir le fait que ça je trouve pas
génial
a contrario sur netflix avec ici ce
format je peux venir zoomer mais ça ne
laisse toujours légèrement ce côté là
c'est pas dérangeant au delà de ça c'est
un smartphone qui est fait tout en verre
qui est franchement beau père dans cette
petite couleur là je le trouve juste
magnifique par contre faut faire gaffe
alors déjà les traces de doigts et de
deux les rayures moi ce que je vous
conseille franchement là dessus c'est de
le protéger
vous mettez une coque de protection et
vous lui mettez devant une protection
compatible bien évidemment avec le
lecteur d'empreintes digitales heures il
y en a justement que je trouve pas mal
c'est que ça risque de toucher ton et la
coque tout va bien cette coque là elle
est cool elle va bien voyez ça s'emboîte
facilement s'en protège c'est joli c'est
magnifique c'est une comme déchets rhino
shield que je trouve franchement
intéressante
alors bon j'en ai plusieurs vous avez
les coques pour le s10 plus ce qui est
juste là vous avez la coque pour le s10
qui est là et qui va très bien et vous
avez le cras garde pour lui es10 plus
alors c'est une alternative qui est pas
mal ça répond de ce que vous voulez moi
je préfère mettre un cocon entière parce
que je trouve que voyez derrière comme
celle du verre ça protège mais le crunch
garde ça peut être pas mal aussi
vous le prenez vous venez de mettre
dedans comme ça au pav pas paf paf ça
vous le protège donc ça vient vraiment
le surélever par contre si derrière vous
mettez sur un taux qu'il ya un peu de
relief un peu de volume c'est peu quand
même venir vous le vous le frottez bon à
côté de ça c'est quand même pas mal
donc ça c'est plutôt bien et en plus ce
frenchy de la fabrique des protections
d'écran complètement compatible avec le
lecteur d'empreintes digitales
ultrasonique si vous intéresse vous a
mis un code promo de 10 % directement
dans la description ça c'est plutôt cool
énorme point positif c'est cet écran il
est franchement hyper hyper hyper
magnifique
très très très lumineux vous le regardez
sur tous les angles un angle de vision
qui est juste complètement hallucinant
pour regarder des films ce que vous
voulez il est vraiment génial moi
j'adore je trouve vraiment vraiment
super pour du contenu multimédia
c'est vraiment magnifique samsung a
continué à mettre la barre très très
haute au niveau cet écran alors qu'on
aime ou qu'on n'aime pas la bulle on ne
peut pas du tout le reprocher la qualité
de cet écran qui est vraiment
complètement génial et en plus prévenir
paramétrer vous allez dans affichage
vous pouvez venir filtrer la lumière
bleue directement dati ça c'est cool
vous avez un mode nuit qui va venir vous
le font c'est économiser la batterie
c'est pas mal aussi
c'est très très très sympa et un truc
est vraiment génial c'est le mode
d'écran avant samsung a tendance à nous
mettre des écrans avec ilker un peu
cheap au niveau du des couleurs il y
avait un côté patron naturel là
justement ils l'ont intégré directement
c'est le mode naturel
vous pouvez passer sur un truc un peu
plus punchy comme avant c'est le mode
vif boyer lorelei et de la colorimétrie
sur la vidéo ça peut être un petit peu
plus compliqué mais c'est pas si vous
vous rendez compte
là sur l'hélice la différence entre les
vies fait naturel les couleurs sont très
douces sont vraiment très très belle et
ça je trouve que c'est vraiment sa part
gardé la le pamplemousse je passe en
vivre les couleurs là elles sont hyper
flashy
c'est un peu trop le mode naturel est
vraiment magnifique
il est compatible hd r10 plus pour
regarder des vidéos netflix youtube
c'est un vrai régal je crois que c'est
un des meilleurs écrans que j'ai pu voir
jusqu'à présent vraiment samsung a
toujours fait de bons écrans ça c'est
pas nouveau mais il continue à
progresser et pour moi ce s10 plus même
le s10 1 ils sont vraiment au-dessus de
ce qu'on avait l'année dernière sur les
9,9 plus donc ça continue à progresser
samsung toujours plus dans le game et en
termes du très haut de gamme sont
franchement juste et normes alors en
plus ce qui est cool c'est que vous avez
un socle c'est l'exynos 9820 qui couplé
à 8 gigas de ram
il tourne super bien alors sur les
résultats en tout tout vous aurez pas
les meilleurs scores par rapport à un
qualcomm c'est un dragon 855 ou par
rapport à la dernière puce de apple
néanmoins franchement il fera super bien
la faire le fait d'avoir 8
g derrière vous apporte complètement de
la fluidité si vous avez l'impression
que ça ralentit derrière ça me
semblerait quand même relativement
bizarre typiquement pour jouer un peu
ibg ça va franchement bien c'est très
très fluide vous voyez il n'y a
absolument aucun lag aucun
ralentissement c'est juste génial up
j'aimerais bien descendre en plus
derrière en termes de techno en a tout
ce qu'il faut on a du wifi 6 on a du
bout tout 5.0 il est franchement très
complet en plus qui coule c'est que vous
avez la prise jack qui est conservé
alors je sais je sais peut-être lundi
dernier dino a aimé la prise jack
bien que je met franchement avec des
casques sans fil mais ça fait quand même
son affaire et c'est relativement pas
mal si vous voulez effectivement
continuer à utiliser cette prise jack
d'une manière générale le dio est
franchement énorme là dessus écoutez ça
il ya franchement un très gros volume
sonore
vous avez un haut parleur qui est situé
juste là à notre parleurs qui est ici en
renfort
ça vous fait vraiment un son stéréo
alors celui ci sera un peu moins
puissant que celui vous avez là mais par
contre amène beaucoup de sons beaucoup
puissance et pour côté multimédia
immersion c'est vraiment génial
lorsque vous le mettez à fond le casque
je parle fort parce que j'entends rien
c'est vraiment très très fort il ya
beaucoup de sons c'est juste énorme
la qualité vraiment là c'est hyper hyper
hyper appréciable là dessus aussi pour
moi il ya une vraie maîtrise donc ça
c'est déjà un poids très très fort sur
le smartphone c'est la maîtrise en
termes de multimédia pour regarder du
contenu c'est vacances c'est vraiment
génial il ya une belle maîtrise au
niveau de la vidéo l'écran est juste
magnifique
hyper lumineux très très très agréable
l'audio est génial si ce n'est cette
petite bulle au million moyennement fans
autant n'arrive biennale à cacher comme
ça autant lorsque vous mettez une vidéo
youtube plein écran vous pouvez pas y
couper
néanmoins pour l'expérience gaming
expérience multimédia divertissement
vidéo c'est un excellent smartphone il
pour moi probablement un des meilleurs
smartphones si ce n'est pas le plus de
ça c'est un smartphone qui est endurant
vous avez une très grosse batterie de
4100 milliampères heures d'un point de
vue général la batterie vous pouvez la
garder deux jours sans problème sauf en
cas d'utilisation intensive tout au
début j'ai fait un voyage en train de
l'utiliser pendant trois heures et demie
et la batterie j'ai gardé une journée
j'étais un peu déçu puis je me suis
rendu compte à l'usagé mais au final on
l'a guère franchement deux jours si vous
êtes sur un usage modéré point un petit
peu négatif là dessus c'est que vous
n'avez pas de recharge rapide
vous avez un chargeur de 15 watts
uniquement à l'intérieur il vous faut
une heure et demie pour recharger vous
armer de patience après ce qui est cool
c'est la recharge l'inversé j'ai mes
petits une galaxie buzz qui sont là si
la recharge avec ses biens à côté de ça
ça va quand même vous videz votre
batterie donc vraiment utilisé en cas de
nécessité
mais si vous avez besoin de dépanner ou
si vous avez un problème est que vous
êtes fous batterie vous pouvez y aller
ça c'est franchement cool
l'ol s'est franchement aussi vachement
bien one way est cool vous avez plein de
petites options qui sont très sympas par
exemple dans l'affichage vous allez dans
barre de navigation et là vous pouvez
avoir navigation soit avec les touches
de navigation je dirais un peu standards
comme vous avez sur du smartphone un peu
classique soit des mouvements
bon ça c'est pareil c'est un grand
classique mais c'est franchement c'est
très sympa ça marche très bien c'est
cool
donc ça c'est ça aussi voilà ça c'est
plutôt pas mal autre point très très
très intéressant c'est le bien-être
numérique ça ça se développe de plus en
plus vous voyez aujourd'hui ce que j'ai
fait 40 de déverrouillage les
notifications vous pouvez en plus venir
programmés si vous voulez le désactiver
le soir le met en échelle de gris pour
que vous ayez un peu votre smartphone en
stand-by enfin il ya pas mal de petites
choses qui sont très intéressantes pour
vous rendre compte de votre consommation
ça c'est assez cool voyez temps d'écran
la gelée sur plusieurs jours et je vois
vraiment les applications sur lesquelles
j'ai passé du temps maintenant le gros
gros gros point sur ce smartphone c'est
la partie photo vidéo qui est le
deuxième usage le plus important je
dirai après la partie écran multimédia
je vais pas rentrer d'un côté technique
ce qui est très intéressant est ce qui
est vraiment très très très très bien
réussi sur ce smartphone
il est très simple de prise en main pour
la photo vous pouvez faire plein de
choses avec 3 que c'est la meilleure
façon d'expliquer ça donc il est très
simple de faire plein de choses avec
et surtout il est dans le
vous portez une chute si vous voulez
vous pouvez vraiment rentré dans les
réglages faire plein de choses
personnalisés mais l'idée d'un
smartphone c'est on le prend c'est joli
tac je prends la photo j mort talisman
parle plus c'est vraiment l'adn de ce
produit c'est vraiment ce qui est super
parce que les trois caméras sont
vraiment très intéressante vous avez la
première caméra c'est un grand-angle ce
mec là la fameuse lentilles ouverture
variable commandé sur le galaxy s 9 et
s9 plus l'année dernière qui va vraiment
être excellentes en faible luminosité
vous avez la deuxième caméra avec un
téléobjectif x 2 pour venir vous et vous
avez le très grand angle qui vous permet
de capturer des choses que vous ne
pourriez pas capturer si vous n'aviez
pas ce très grand angle ça c'est
franchement cool et à l'avant vous avez
deux cameyrac notamment être là pour le
mode portrait c'est pas mal la caméra
avant pour moi elle ne transforme pas il
faudrait une meilleure stabilisation
c'est tout moi je suis plutôt un bon
crash test là dessus et je suis pas
hyper fan de la caméra avant elle est
pas mal mais on pourrait faire mieux par
contre que vous avez à l'arrière c'est
juste topissime en termes d'usagé c'est
vraiment hyper simple de venir faire des
photos vous avez vos trois modes lavoyer
hop ça c'est normal ça c'est le x 2 et
là c'est le grand âge c'est instantané
c'est facile c'est franchement cool
alors après vous pouvez aller plus loin
sur l'optimisateur de seine
vous avez pas mal de petites options de
petits réglages autre truc qui est
vraiment génial c'est sur la vidéo parce
que vous avez une superbe stabilisation
ici que vous pouvez venir activer ou
désactiver très très très facilement ça
fait un boulot incroyable
et croyez moi tant de stabilisation
franchement q qu'allez vous avez tous
vos paramètres après le super ralenti le
ralenti l'hyper las le fameux mode
portrait il ya un mot de trop s'ils
voulaient vraiment venir gratter vos
propres paramètres les modes panorama
alimentation et instagram
parce que ce qui est génial avec le mode
instagram là dessus c'est que lorsque
vous allez prendre une photo c'est pas
voulu intégrer directement instagram
alors qu'avant instagram venez faire une
capture en route de votre écran en gros
ça vous la compresser le rendu était
beaucoup moins beau là par contre vous
êtes directement dans instagram est une
vraie belle intégration
ça c'est franchement génial d'autant
plus qu'on sait qu'aujourd'hui la partie
photo c'est vraiment pour le partage sur
les réseaux sociaux
c'est patent pour faire une photo ce
faire un album en ligne les imprimés
lusage numéro un c'est parfait sur les
réseaux et instagram number one donc ça
qu'on coup c'est vraiment bien pensé de
la part de samsung
j'ai fait plein de tests en conditions
de bonne luminosité en faible lui
auzits et je me suis posé la question
est-ce que ce galaxy s 10 plus c'est à
l'auteur de google pixels 3 sur la photo
de nuit
c'était vraiment le le point important
sinon il n'y est pas et alors s'il n'y a
pas non plus un écart monstrueux dire
soit toujours de belles photos de nuit
mais je m'attendais à ce qu'ils
travaillent logiciel qui soit
complètement hallucinant parce que sans
pixel 3 que vous avez juste une caméra
et là vous avez trois caméras google
avec une seule caméra avec un traitement
logiciel sur optimisé n'arrête vous
faire des choses complètement
hallucinante là c'est pas aussi bien
mais c'est franchement très bien et
surtout ce qui est vraiment très très
très bien avec le smartphone c'est qu'il
est hyper polyvalent photos de nuit
photos de jour vidéo vidéo stabiliser
post sur instagram en direct c'est
vraiment un excellent smartphone alors
c'est peut-être pas le meilleur sur la
photo de nuit n'était pas excellent
partout mais par contre il est très
équilibré et vous pourrez faire plein de
choses avec sur la photo franchement
vous regretterez pas
expérience de meilleure saison guillaume
tpr et là bonjour quelqu'un de bien bon
j'ai un dilemme alors concentré vous ça
va être vrai donc là on est en direct
sur la gauche et 30 ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après il ya pas de petites optimisations
mais ce qui est aussi très intéressante
aux smartphones c'est qu'il est
franchement tout terrain du fait que
vous pouvez filmer avec un côté un peu
action cam stabiliser c'est franchement
intéressant lorsque vous allez faire une
photo si vous ne mettez pas complètement
droit l'intelligence artificielle va
venir vous faire une photo complètement
droite ya pas mal d'intelligence
d'arrière d'optimisation c'est
franchement très intéressant du coup ça
vous améliorent le smartphone mais d'un
côté complètement invisible vous vous en
rendez pas compte donc ça pour moi c'est
franchement génial en plus de ça il est
certifié ip 68 résistants à l'eau et à
la poussière
maintenant ce qui était un petit peu
moins cool c'est le prix forcément qui
dit smartphone très haut de gamme avec
un produit aussi bien réussi 10
smartphones forcément cher cher
aujourd'hui 1900 euros mais pour 1900
euros vous aurez franchement un
excellent produit
s'il vous botte je vous ai mis un lien
en bas dans la description et surtout
n'oubliez pas très important protéger le
les coques rhinochill vous avez la
protection d'écran avec le capteur
d'empreinte ultrasons qui sont
franchement très très très très bien
code promo en bas profitez-en
si vous avez un ace 9,99 s9 plus est ce
que ça vaut le coup de changer non ce
smartphone est juste excellent il ya une
amélioration vraiment significative avec
plein de nouvelles fonctionnalités par
rapport aux smartphones de l'année
dernière mais le s9 reste quand même
franchement dans la course par contre si
vous avez cette es6 ou un smartphone
d'une autre marque les un peu
vieillissants ou alors pas à ce niveau
là ça vaut le coup de changer je le
trouve vraiment bien c'est pour moi un
des meilleurs smartphones 2019 si ce
n'est pas le meilleur de ce début
d'année parce que ce n'est qu'un début
ici quelques jours on va aller
rencontrer le paie 30 petrof profa mon
avis aussi on va de très très très belle
surprise mais ça on en reparlera d'ici
quelques jours en attendant ce samsung
galaxy s 10 plus il est tant pis si je
vous parle de samsung galaxy s 10e dans
quelques jours donc
abonnez-vous comme ça vous saurez tout
et puis je vous invite à aller consulter
ma playlist où je vous parle de tous les
nouveaux smartphones du moment comme ça
vous saurez tout voilà dit pas ce que
vous en pensez
est ce que vous le trouvez bien est-ce
que vous avez cette couleur je trouve
franchement top
est ce que vous êtes convaincus par le
côté caméra et surtout grosse question
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la bulle on
ne parle pas dans coche
c'est très intéressant parce que voyez
samsung n'a jamais fait dans coche et là
un moment la question s'est posée de
comment venir intégrer un grand module
caméra à l'avant du smartphone alors
l'encoche franchement on ne fera jamais
non pas fait là dessus et ils ont
franchement eu raison maintenant est ce
que vous trouvez que la bulle
c'est une bonne idée est ce que vous
trouvez que c'est quelque chose de
réussi
est ce que c'est une bonne idée ou est
ce que c'est une fausse bonne idée vous
marquez tout ça en bas en commentaire on
en parle ensemble ou nous embrasse soyez
sages à demain ciao